في القضيه التي هزت الراي العامه العربيه
والامريكيه تفاصيل جديده تتكشف يوما بعد
يوم فالتحقيقات لا تزال مستمره على الرغم
من تاجيل جلسه الاستماع الاولى للمتهمه
بقتل الشعب السعودي المبتعث الوليد
الغريبي نيكول رودجرز ويعتبر المحققون ان
الادله التي جمعوها حتى اللحظه كافيه
لادانتها بما انه فيه ادله
من محامي للمحامي الثالثه هي قابله
للتاجيل برضو
لكن الموعد في 12 ابريل
موعد الجلسه الاولى يعني
تمثل فيها اول مره امام القاضي لك ابنته
19 عاما المتهمه بقتل الشاب السعودي
المبتعث الوليد الغريبي سلمت نفسها للشرطه
الامريكيه بعد ايام من الجريمه في ولايه
نيوجيرسي المجاوره بعد اطلاق الشرطه في
فيلادلفيا حمله على مستوى البلاد للعثور
عليها ولكنها حتى اللحظه لم تعترف
بجريمتها
وبانتظار جلسه المحاكمه كشف والد الغريبي
ان الجامعه التي كان ابنه على وشك التخرج
منها قررت تكريمه ويخرج يكرر بتخرجه او عن
شيء رمزي لكنه مهم بالنسبه لنا
بيعملوا حاجه يمكن يعني تبقى اكثر من فقط
انهم يخرجون
بتسميه مكان بالجامعه باسم الوليد وهذا
شيء مقدر جدا
واعتراف كبير من يعني جامعه بحجمها
في الجامعه التي قضى فيها الوليد اخر
سنواته تجولت العربيه وسالنا اصدقائه
ومسؤولين عن هذا الشاب الذي اسر بابتسامته
كلوب من تبع قضيته
كان طالبا متفوقا وذا موهبه كبيره في علوم
الكمبيوتر خساره كبيره لاهله اولا
ولاصدقائه ولنا ايضا لا يمكنني ان اصف
دمااثه اخلاقه ولا طيبه قلبه وشهمته
بمساعده كل من يحتاجه لمساعده دون حتى ان
يطلبها
ومع صديقي الوليد ابو عبد العزيز المحسن
تحدثنا عن الوليد وتعرفنا عليه عن قرب
تفاصيل مؤلمه وبتقطع القلب
مثل ما قلت لك مثل الوليد
بحد ذاته مؤلم جدا الله يعين امه وابوه
والله يعني كان برضو
المسار القانوني لقضيات الغريبيه ربما
يطول لاسباب تقنيه بحته كمثل تدعيه كورونا
على القضاء الامريكي وما تبعها من تاجيل
لعدد كبير من القضايا للتسليمان العربيه
فيلادلفيا